hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carroll and
I'm of the opinion that we don't talk
about games enough at least we don't
talk about games enough in an
intellectual sense and as sort of the
theory of games what are games why do we
do them clearly there's a whole bunch of
people playing games I just looked up
the numbers online and we spend over
twice as much on video games these days
as we do on movies despite the fact
there's a lot more coverage of movies in
TV and magazines two-thirds of American
households play video games or at least
have someone in there playing video
games for more than three hours per week
so video games pervade our lives as do
games more generally right chess go card
games etc but what is a game what's the
definition of it and why are we so
attracted them why do they fascinate us
so I think that my cat's Ariel and
Caliban in some sense play games Ariel
least plays fetch but we human beings go
to great lengths to invent completely
arbitrary rules play by them and then
invest enormous amounts of emotion into
whether we win or lose or how we do
playing this game so today we have on
one of the world's leading people who
does think about these issues in detail
Franklin is a very active game designer
he's designed a number of video games
gearheads drop 7 which is a famous
iPhone mobile phone game CSI crime city
as well as various real world games
where people are out there in the
streets actually playing by certain
rules but he's also the director of the
game Center at NYU so his part of his
job is to take the bigger picture to
really ask what games are where they're
going so there's a very fun conversation
I do have to admit that it was in an
extremely unusual setting that we had
the conversation this was a live
recording at the Santa Fe Institute's
interplanetary Festival in Santa fé
which is a very fun event but to be
honest the recording was in a big space
in a big tent with lots of other things
going on so the amount of background
noise is considerable and what's worse I
wasn't using my own equipment I was
using the local equipment there and the
good news is that Frank's
microphone was really good so you'll
hear him well my microphone sadly was
not as good and also I was because of
that trying to project so it sounds like
I'm shouting the entire time for the
entire podcast but you know I've done
what I can to save the audio file make
it as listenable as possible and like I
said Frank who's the one you're there to
listen to is actually very clear in this
recording so I think it's such a good
conversation on the substantive level
that it's well worth listening to
so let's go
[Music]
all right Frank Lantz welcome to the
mindscape podcast thanks great to be
here so I don't want to put into words
what it is you do although I've already
done that in the intro but you both
design games and have this sort of
academic position so why don't you tell
us a little bit about who you are what
you do what did it what are the games
that you've been responsible for well
yeah I'm a game designer have been
making games for a long time and also
teach game design at NYU I serve both of
these
simultaneously the game design
department is in the Tisch School of the
Arts it's just the same school that has
the film school and acting and things
like that and the idea is that the
instructors there are also practitioners
so you know we are professional game
developers and people who have an
ongoing career in a practice and so
that's what I've been doing for for many
years now and as a game designer in New
York I made a lot of weird kind of
experimental games I had a small studio
called area code we specialized in
location-aware games and street games
games that took place in physical spaces
that incorporated computers but weren't
on computers they weren't video games
yeah instead we were sort of taking
advantage of the emerging kind of
ubiquitous computing technology to
create new kinds of game experiences
that brought back social interaction
into the mix so I did a lot of games
like that I taught a class in in that
style of game at NYU and the students in
that class made a game called pack
Manhattan which was translating the game
of pac-man onto the grid onto the street
grid of New York City and so that's the
kind of thing that that we did my studio
did a bunch of games we made a bunch of
large-scale social games for Facebook we
also did a game called drop seven which
you may be the only favorite of mine I
spent many hours playing drop seven on
the iPhone nice nice and yeah so I've
made lots and lots of games over the
years and
recently a couple of years ago I made a
game called Universal paperclips which
was the sort of first time that I had
sat down to program a game that again
myself from from scratch and so that was
a fun experience and that's the the most
recent thing on you take over your life
programming something like that yeah I
was deeply satisfying and and and a
learning experience
I should mention I'm very new at this in
the sense that this is the first ever
time that mindscape has done a live
podcast so for those of you listening
over the podcast radio Internet network
we are here live at the Santa Fe
interplanetary festival it will also
explain why you may hear noises in the
background like what I think was a
theremin was just going on but it may
very well have been an alien creature
talking it's special language because
we're here at the interplanetary
festival anything can happen so that's
ok we're all about experiences and new
ones and seeing how things go so one of
the wonderful things I like Frank about
your work is that you you have designed
games you program games you coded but
you also think carefully about the
bigger picture which is my favorite
thing and our favorite thing here online
scape so let's just be as big as we can
what what is a game what what qualifies
some activity as being a game rather
than being something else well I think
of game as cultural category so it
doesn't have a very precise definition
that will allow you to distinguish
between things that are games and art
games in some kind of automatic way by
looking at their internal
characteristics and identifying them
instead it it is you know it represents
a kind of a broad category of human
action and I think of it as being a
creative form and something like an art
form an aesthetic form so something like
literature or music or film dance you
know that kind of thing
and so it's gonna have all the same kind
of ambiguity to precisely identify what
is or isn't a game but to me it is
is the art form of interactivity it is
the it is the creative form of of
designing experiences for people you're
still trying to create something
meaningful beautiful interesting popular
expressive but you're doing it by
crafting people's interactions by
crafting their choices and their actions
so I like that the art form of
interactivity so the I apologize to the
audience like I there's an audience in
front of me so I feel I should project
my voice to them but the podcast
listeners whom you like why is he
shouting on the podcast he doesn't do
that sorry take it into consideration
but interactivity then clearly so that's
the thing like it doesn't matter that
there's a goal doesn't matter you can
win or lose it does matter there are
other people I said there's a matter
that you're not just looking at the work
of art you are interacting with it
that's what makes it a game yeah and I
think things like having a goal win
state and lost state those are the kinds
of things that lots of games do have so
you know when we're looking to identify
whether something is a game or not
having those qualities make it more
likely that it's a game in the same
sense that music is is about sound but
you know in some cases music might be
about silence right so the absence of
sound doesn't mean that it's not a piece
of music for this famous John Cage piece
you know it just it's like these are the
kinds of things by which we it's like a
family resemblance thing you know if it
can Stein famously sort of used game the
word game as an example of how hard it
is to define anything because you know
but but yeah there's this family
resemblances you they do tend to be
about goals but not always and in
recently game designers have really been
exploring the space of games that are
explicitly not about goals so that
that's you know I went through a phase
when I was quasi active in Second Life
and I never did second life I know I
didn't myself and I'm familiar with it
yeah well I I got into it because there
was a podcast that was in second life so
there was an interviewer and so forth
Jennifer my wife hosted was one of the
many hosts of his podcast and I gave
public lectures
in Second Life my impression was always
for those of you who don't know it's a
massively online game in some sense but
they never say you had an avatar there
was a world you built a virtual world
there weren't goals though it was an
open world in the broadest sense way
here it is here's your play box here's
your sandbox go play with it and I think
it kind of faltered because of that
there there's other virtual worlds like
world war of warcraft other games that
are much more popular because you can
still build the world but there's also a
way to win or lose
yeah moment a moment I actually I'm
fascinated by Second Life I think it's
more interesting now in its moribund
state as this is like abandoned virtual
world yeah that they do you see people
like take tours of it like they're going
to Chernobyl you know and there's this
big strange decaying ruins of
corporate-sponsored like avant-garde our
locations it's very weird and cool well
it was weird to me because because it's
Second Life it tried to mimic life like
you could have a house we had a house we
had a cat in our house yeah but then you
could apparently just walk into other
people's house and rifle around and that
was weird and you didn't know whether
that was okay or not yeah I I mean I
always thought that the sort of
fascination with virtual worlds was a it
happened in like a 90s and early 2000s
it was a little bit misplaced you know
the idea that for me as a game designer
what was interesting about World of
Warcraft was not that it was a virtual
world that happened to be a game it was
that it was a game that incorporated a
virtual world right and the fact that it
was a game I thought was a really
important part of that experience right
because a game like a virtual world has
the implication that this is just
another type of social space but but a
game is a kind of theatrical like it's
kind of like expressive like we know
we're entering into a kind of
performance and yeah and so it's
important in World of Warcraft that it
isn't just things like you know race and
politics it's this strange
representation of race and politics you
know and then I was a horde I was I
always said I was a troll in World of
Warcraft and of course there was a horde
versus a lion
and it was this you know big kind of
underlying motivation for your play and
you know I hated the Alliance of quorum
but but it was it wasn't real hate right
it's not real hate taking place in a
virtual space it was the it was this
strange kind of performative hate which
is similar to you know what you get when
you are performing in a play or looking
at a painting or reading a poem you know
what I mean I think that's the important
thing but it can also bleed over into
the real world I mean fans of one sports
team can be very not friendly with fans
but other sports it's true and I think
when you get violence in sports fandom
is where you see a failure of the of the
kind of ritual transformative aspect I
think when it's working
sports fandom gives you this kind of
strange toy version of the kind of
totalitarian identity that we get when
we just feel like oh I'm disappearing
into the mom I become a Mets fan or I'd
become a Yankees fan and and I get to
experience the pleasure of what it's you
know what it feels like to get rid of my
actual identity all the nuance and
subtlety of being a person and being
part of all kinds of different
communities and instead I get to plunge
into this simplistic atavistic you know
thing and that's kind of be beautiful
because it's not real you could be a
member of a tribe without all of the
terrible baggage that can sometimes go
along and it works because we know in
this even when we commit fully to it it
is bracketed in a way B and that that to
me is part of what makes you know sports
and and games in general feel like they
belong alongside with the arts well one
of the things I noticed in second life
with this podcast that Jennifer was a
host of was so she would interview
people like you interview people in a
podcast she would invite them on and
they generally wouldn't have second life
characters already's they would design
it from scratch and you saw there were
only two types they were like the people
who designed the most sexually
attractive version of themselves right
like buff beautiful and glamorous
praises or people who went completely
crazy
they were a unicorn or they were a flock
of butterflies and and that freedom to
be something completely different was
very valuable to them yeah but it's
still theirs they're still expressing
something that was inside their real
selves yeah and I think I think you see
that in role-playing games as well when
people design avatars for themselves in
in you know Morrowind or or you know any
kind of RPG they're they're you know
kind of big playing with identity in
that same way and it brings me brings us
back I should have asked this even
before what is a game what is playing
like cats and dogs play right it's not
purely human I actually have a cat who
plays fetch she's like a little puppy so
bring it back and her brother won't do
that but so somewhere along evolutionary
evolutionary time our presumably we like
everything else in evolution we
developed some mental machinery for some
reason and we repurposed it for another
reason
yeah so the hunting and the gathering or
whatever got repurposed as play do we
know a lot about the evolution of play
and what purposes it serves yeah I mean
I think there's a deep scholarship about
play that comes out of anthropology and
also sociology and psychology and
development science and and I did one of
the things that's fascinating about
games
is that it you know it taps into this
this deep and ancient form of behavior
which is not only there at the beginning
of human culture but really predates
human culture there's a the sociologist
who is Zynga wrote this famous book
called homo Luden's which is about how
play really is the origin point of human
culture like human yeah human culture
and civilization comes out of play
assembly it's one of many grandiose
claims that you could either believe or
disbelieve equally well yeah it is but
we like quizzing so we're gonna give
them and we're gonna give him the nod in
this case but but yeah I mean so what as
for what it is I think it has something
to do with the power of free exploration
a lot of what we do
is is kind of bound and guided by by our
goals and our and our rules of
interaction and then some things we do
are more exploratory they're more
improvisational they are there more
unbounded they involve things that are
maybe random or you know trial and error
and and you know we're if I pick up this
bottle I know what I'm supposed to do
which is hold it up to my lips and drink
it but if I just pour some out on the
table
that's that's playful right because I'm
I'm exploring the the range of possible
actions I can take with this with this
bottle and it's not just the ones that
we think of immediately because we're
kind of programmed to behave in certain
programmed ways it's all the different
ways like all that everything is I can
do with this bottle right so that's
that's play and I think that's one half
of games I think what's super
interesting is that in games you get
this idea play wild improvisation kind
of unbounded energetic in you know
excess and imaginative kind of
exploration and it's it's also its in
conversation with the opposite with
structure with rules
with with goals with arbitrary goals
like oh I'm going to you know tie one
hand behind my back and now what can I
do with this bottle like just like like
and and so these two things are kind of
in conversation in games right clay and
and rules kind of freedom and structure
rules seem to be one of the things that
goes almost inevitably along with the
concept of games right and like you say
we make them up it's it's always been
psychologically fascinating to me that
we invent rules and then we stick to
them like we invented them like and or
the goal like okay create you know win
your golden prize for playing the game a
certain number of times on your iPhone
this week but then they become very
important to us despite the fact that we
know they're entirely arbitrary yeah and
in games we get to play with rules and
we get to submit ourselves to them we
get to experience the
pleasure of being bound by a little
arbitrary system and there is a
particular kind of pleasure there but
then we also are given a chance to to to
recognize how rules are constructed like
as a game designer my job is to make
rules and and and as a player we
encounter a game we voluntarily step
into it submit ourselves to the rules
but then we then we finish we stop
playing and we step back and we realize
oh well that's the characters of this
little set of rules but it could have
been a different way and even as a
player you get to play with the rules
you say what if we do it again but this
time let's tie both hands behind her
back or this time you know let's let's
not try to do this thing let's try to do
this other thing right and and so it
gives you a sense of how rules are
pliable and if I'm playing solitaire
let's say I'm playing with real cards
not just on the phone and if I lose if I
can't you know finish the deck I feel
bad I'm tempted to cheat like why is
that well because I think part of what
you get from a game is this little sense
that you're being tested and that it's a
little puzzle solitaire is like a little
puzzle and when you do well at solitaire
it's partly a reflection of the fact
that you're smart and so when you do
poorly
that's yourself image yeah so it's
almost like wanting to take your
temperature again to see if maybe you
could get hotter you know a this
wonderful talk for the audience out
there you should look online for a talk
the Frank gave that involves two games
that he compares and contrasts go and
poker and let's take them in order
because they're both fascinating for the
own reasons go of course it's Japanese
originally Chinese original Chinese
originally okay it's the it's two Asian
cultures what chess is two Western
cultures and it's very formal and rigid
and the rules are very clear and people
get into it and you make this wonderful
analogy that it becomes like a martial
art in some sense it's a form of
discipline to become a good go player
yeah go is an example of the kind of
game that is a very hard deep
cognitive problem like the kind that
scientists wrestle with but totally
separate from the the idea in science
that that you're working on a problem
for a particular reason because it fits
into some larger framework because by
solving this problem you'll be able to
solve this other problem or because it
might lead down stream to some
engineering breakthroughs in the case of
go you are just wrestling with that
problem for its own sake yeah yeah and
and and it's it's a very deep and
beautiful game and it's been around for
thousands of years and it's another
great example of how strange games are
as an art form because we have I mean
they're not that many works of
literature or music that people have
been interacting with for thousands of
years and they're still doing it in the
same way they're still getting the
similar kind of value out of it they're
still thinking about it and
participating with it in a similar way
yeah and it's it's it's a remarkable
game we miss if we didn't mention the
computers are now better than you yes
it's this great example of how games are
often the sort of ultimate testbed for
artificial intelligence and go is this
iconic kind of quintessential AI problem
which just recently tumbled and maybe is
the sort of last sort of the last game
the last kind of fully you know
full-fledged human game that humans are
really good at we'll get to poker in a
second yeah and but yeah it took longer
for computers to win it go against the
best bill players then at chess it did
and people I think a little bit over
interpreted that they were like oh well
chess of course of course computers
gonna get a chess because look at it you
can see that it's it's combinatorial and
you can just crunch you know through and
look at all the possibilities but go go
requires intuition and deep insight and
all these kind of ineffable I think
there was a sense of that it may be
especially I'm on game designers for
whom one of the beauties of go is that
it does require intuition and and if
there is an ineffable quality like you
talk about things like shape and these
kind of nebulous concepts like it's
not just sitting down and crunching
through if I go there you go there I go
there you go there you actually do have
these hard to pin down concepts and so I
think people thought elbow this will be
our bulwark against AI and it'll last
for a long time because it didn't it
didn't last for those who have never
seen it 19 by 19 those 19 by 19 grade
and you put either white or black yeah
you can alternate black and white stones
so I mean part of me wants to say I'll
be a scientist here for a second it's a
finite game there's only a finite number
of things that can happen shorten but
the other part says but that numbers
really really big so of course when real
human beings play go just like playing
chess we don't in our brains try to go
through every combinatorial possibility
we use heuristics we use our intuition
we look at the shape with the board we
get a feeling you talk about the energy
that comes off of different
configurations of the pieces yeah and of
course then you ask the computer to do
it it was I heard a talk here at SantaFe
Institute in fact by former professional
go player who like many professional go
players gave up when the computer won
mmm because they can't compete now with
a computer but what we one of the things
we learned was one of the things was
holding the artificial intelligence back
from becoming a really good go player
was that they trained it on human games
first and it actually turned out to be
much better if they just let it play
against itself yeah ever poisoning it
with human that was the real headline
with alphago is that it got so much
better when we stopped trying to seed it
with the the centuries of knowledge that
humans had developed with all of our
insights all of our heuristic all of our
all of our ways of teaching go we just
left that out and instead we gave it the
rules and then we gave it a technique
for playing against itself and a
preference for winning and it did so
much better it was really a kind of an
interesting lesson there about about
humility and some of the players used
words like he was playing against an
alien because the computer used concepts
that the humans hadn't thought of before
but it was still beautiful like the
thing is that the the go experts who
were watching alphago still found the
moves that alphago made that were
surprising to be
the exquisite and so that was exciting
Jersey and it's a beauty that is on one
hand non-human or inhuman because it
surprised us and came out of and on the
other hand deeply human because it is go
itself expressing itself like it is an a
project like alphago is the results of
hundreds of people thousands of people
collaborating and working together and
building on each other's insights and
knowledge to make this piece of
engineering so in some sense it's deeply
human yeah I think that's a that's a
nice thing it was humans who had the
motivation to invent the game right the
computer never got to play another game
it wouldn't get frustrated yeah yeah
that's what comes from us human beings
yeah and that's why I like this this
idea of using games like go almost as a
tool of self-discipline right as a way
it's almost like a meditative monk like
or martial art like practicing your
training ourselves to be a slightly
better people than we are yes it's the
way I like to think about about it is
that it is it's a way of thinking about
thinking go itself is a way of thinking
about thinking and artificial
intelligence is also a way of thinking
about thinking and when people play go I
think this is true for for as long as
people have played go they've been doing
a kind of artificial intelligence
research well they've been thinking
what's possible if I take this little
isolated problem and devote all of my
thinking in fact devote my entire life
like a serious go player like a serious
player of any you know like truly deep
competitive game gives up the rest of
their life to explore this thing yeah
and anxious and and so in the case of a
game like go which is about decision
making what they're doing is saying I'm
going to sacrifice my life in order to
explore in the deepest possible way what
it what it means to solve problems to
what it means to apply every fiber of my
cognitive ability to solving a very
precise and specific kind of problem and
to it and to go deep and to like watch
it unfold it
fascinating and beautiful it's not
trivial even though it's a it's an
extraordinarily simple game with only a
handful of rules well maybe this is the
good place to mention the idea that if
you just say games especially in our
modern culture where that has slightly
the connotation of video games people
worry is a slightly disreputable
connotation right like this is something
that kids do it's distracting them from
more important things if you'd said
chess or go maybe they would sit they
would get the fact that that's a more
elevated supplying thing but is it
really differrent or all games have an
aspect of things um I think people are
right to be suspicious of games I'm a
game designer I've devoted my life to
making games and playing games that I
love them very deeply but games by their
very nature have to live outside of
ordinary life and we should be
suspicious of them like I think art is
the same way right people are also
suspicious of art we spend all your time
like you know reading these these stupid
books you know and and just you know
reading comic books or or you you're
obsessed with with music and you you
know you're like hanging out with your
friends playing that noise instead of
you know doing something practical and
useful um so I think in that sense yeah
games occupied this weird space outside
of our kind of ordinary system of values
and they should that's their job is to
be out there doing weird stuff and and
exploring the the you know the edges of
what we what we know and think and
imagine so it's my part of my job is the
podcast toast is to be slightly contrary
and play the devil's advocate a little
bit here so some NGO or chess might be
very beautiful even world of warcraft
can be beautiful its own way there are
some games that are really really simple
and yet it is hard to ascribe the same
level of beauty to them and yet they
really get us they get their hooks into
us yes and they become addictive yes as
a whole there's one of the gaming
companies called addicting games that's
they shoot for maybe tetris was the
first very well known one on the
computer but this is you know this is
definitely a goal of certain game
designers to make a
very simple game that will prevent
people from ever putting their phone and
I and I think we could just we could
look at slot machines as a case in point
of this right slot machines are games I
would I would say and there are there is
a very dark energy to slot machines
slot machines ruin people's lives
not everyone I mean there's some people
who have a healthy relationship to slot
machines and they actually get some
meaning and and pleasure and and and joy
and and in beauty out of slot machines
and but you know make literally no skill
by the way right you're pushing a button
yes yeah that's the the the kind of yeah
the quintessential version of the slot
machine is no skill you can't be an
advantage gamer who finds slot machines
and like exploits certain payoffs and
use your intelligence to actually get a
little bit of an edge
but let's say in the case you know in
the classic case the slot machine is
just pure randomness
I love the slot machine tournaments
there are I mean yeah you get there are
people who make a living playing slot
machines it's like but anyway um the
thing is so-so slot machines do have a
kind of dark energy and we are right to
be anxious about that and and and and I
think good game designers know that they
have a kind of aversion to that type of
game they recognize that they could do
that you can put that into your game but
but most good game designers want to
make a game that is more than just
compelling it does more than just cause
the player to want to keep doing it if
they want to make the kind of game that
they themselves love the kind of game
that after you played it you're happy
that you did and you look back and you
say oh that added something of value to
my life not oh god I'm sick to my
stomach because I've just wasted my time
and energy and money um and and but it's
it's never that simple right because
sometimes great games can have a little
bit of dark energy in them just like
great art can have a little bit of dark
energy a little self-destructive energy
right and so we don't want it we want to
be careful not to be too dogmatic and
and to say oh well we can apply this
moral filter to gains and understand
what's good and bad about them because
the role of games like the role of art
is not just to be good or bad but to
explore what being good or bad means
right and you can't do that if you start
from a starting point where you're like
well I know what bad is bad sir slot
machines are bad
that's what addiction is bad right No so
part of what a game like my game drops 7
I hope which I which I think is kind of
addictive has addictive elements what I
hope I really hope is that it's not just
addictive but it is in a sense about
addiction like it gives people a kind of
a toy version of a thing that is a
little bit like heroin but also a little
bit like pseudo ku Anna Anna and a
little bit like like Tetris and a little
bit like a painting or a little bit like
a rug or a little bit like weaving um
and it takes all of these things and
combines them in a way that I hope gives
people some insight and perspective into
how their mind works and why why they
enjoy it not not just a kind of like
black box that they disappear into it
makes a lot of sense but I want to say
parenthetically for the cosmology
aficionados in the audience that this is
a different sense of the word dark
energy or is it or is it yes but do we
know anything about neuroscience of what
makes it addicting is there is are there
sweet names that just poke your dopamine
receptors we do you know the
psychologists know a lot about sort of
reward schedules and in the case of slot
machines for example what makes them so
powerfully compulsive is that the
rewards are intermittent yes that we
yeah we're not able to predict them and
so these famous experiments where rats
they push a button and they always get a
pallet they'll do that until they've had
their fill but if they push a button and
occasionally get a pellet they'll do
that until they died yeah they'll do
that so um and so this kind of
intermittent reward schedule is a big
part of what makes something truly
compulsive but I tend to be a little bit
skeptical of that like sometimes I will
get calls from journalists they'll be
like Tommy how these evil corporations
making these addictive mobile games are
using these psychological principles
and um and I have no doubt that these
big companies do employ psychologists
but I actually don't think it's that
easy
um and because I think if it if it were
everyone would do it
yeah right there I think even in the
case of slot machines if you talk to
people who design slot machines they
don't always know what what is going to
be popular you know they'll they'll try
a bunch of different kinds of slot
machines and it turns out oh this Golden
Girls machine is doing amazingly well it
is Batman machine exactly so there's
still this sense of trial and error and
in some sense it's still a kind of a
creative process and I think for me in
terms of games the important thing to
remember is games art culture games are
not primarily technology games are a
form of culture that has this deep
relationship to technology but they are
not simply technology they're not simply
devices they're not things that you plug
in and then you get a hedonic you know
pulse and that they they're like a
coffee machine you know instead they are
more like hats she'd be like why did
everyone wear hats for a while but in
every single man in every social space
where this same for a while that was all
right yeah is it is that addiction you
know it's it's wheat like so I think
games even addictive games have that
weird element in them which makes them
hard to just you can't just plug in a
formula and guarantee that you'll have
something popular or compulsive or
success it's never happened to me but as
it maybe happen to you that you've been
playing a game so much that you fell
asleep and while you were dreaming you
kept playing the game yes in fact I'll
tell you the game that did that to me in
in the most powerful way was a game by
David O'Reilly called everything okay
beautiful game if you've never played it
I really recommend it and played on the
PlayStation and and it's an exploration
of the the thinking of Alan Watts the
greats and philosopher and David who's
this brilliant genius made the game in
such a way that if you stopped
controlling it for a while it sort of
automatically starts playing itself and
so if you just put it the controller
down after a while it'll
slowly start to just kind of randomly do
actions and move through the space and
explore it and I was playing it very
late one night it was very tired and and
it was I was already kind of in this
loopy kind of state of mind and I'm
listening to the voice of Alan Watts you
know talk about transcendence and and
mindfulness and I was drifting out of
consciousness and then occasionally I
would wake up and the and the game would
be playing and I wasn't even sure
whether whether it was way or not
yeah it was a really beautiful
experience well yeah I think there's a
lot to learn that we don't yet know
about the psychology of this my personal
theory about Tetris and even drop seven
and these other games were that there's
some threshold where every time you lost
you felt well if I'd done one little
thing better I would have won so
therefore I should play again I think
that's the mark of a good game in many
cases yeah it may because what what
we're trying to do as designers is
create just that experience where I lost
I ant but there was meaning to my life
like I understand now what I should have
done differently and so what the player
is doing is building up a little model
of the system that you designed and and
and they're doing they have hypotheses
and then they do little experiments and
I think there's a lot of kind of like
toy science in a lot of games and and so
yeah this is this feeling of the player
kind of wanting to understand what
you've made and going deeper and deeper
so that feeling of like oh I know what I
want to try differently this time I love
it I also love it in a game where I get
this feeling that
something here is broken I bet I can
exploit ah I bet there's a thing here
that the designer has not thought of and
so I'm going to use you know like an axe
and I'm not gonna wear any armor and I
bet I'm gonna get this weird mutt and
and so that feeling of something being
almost broken or the potential of it
being broken
to me that's catnip well it goes back to
yeah your self-image right you're you're
playing a game to get reaffirmation that
I so I'm pretty clever here I'm pretty
sneaky being pretty clever let's switch
from go we got off go a bit but this
idea of sublime martial art that we use
to train ourselves to poker which is
actually one of my favorite games uh-huh
and you
you wonderfully contrast this idea
sitting in the tranquil Zen garden and
playing you know very slowly and
deliberately and engaging your most
rational mind to the degenerate gamblers
that we get to the poker community in
Vegas yeah it's it's these are to be
riverboat the the two games that I
played most you know deeply in my life
in some ways are very similar but yeah
they have this pretty good cuz because
go is sort of like the beloved of game
design snobs and it has this it's this
ancient game when it's kind of like a
sacred ritual and there's a lot of
respect and a kind of deep culture and
then poker of course is the game you
play when you're crouched down next to
the slot machines they've set up a
little basil and yeah you're listening
to the chime of the Samba shoes and
they're bringing you free drinks and and
you're not even sure whether you know
you're good or not because you think
you're cleverly exploiting some edge
that you have but maybe you're not maybe
you're you just suck and you don't even
know right so it puts you in this
totally opposite frame of mind one of
those fancy things about poker for me is
that it is clearly advantageous for you
if your fellow players think you're an
idiot because you can exploit that yeah
but there's such an enormous
psychological desire for your fellow
players to think you're brilliant yes
that you resist take advantage of that
yeah
and and it's such a beautiful game
because it involves all of the kind of
problem solving that cognitive problem
solving that goes into go right there's
still lots of math in in poker lots of
ways to apply yourself and develop a
kind of you know serious scholarly
discipline to really plumbing the depths
of how this thing works as a system and
at the same time it's deeply social it's
so much about tapping into to your your
ego and the ego of other people also how
we predict each other right are the
models that we have for each other's
behavior this kind of thing yeah model
what your opponents are going to do and
that's manipulating that model by
talking them by not talking right hiding
but but it involves a kind of empathy
like it you can't be good at poker
unless you can put yourself into the
shoes of your opponent and think what
are they thinking and then they're doing
the same thing
you so you get the strange reciprocal
quality what are they thinking I'm
thinking and and it's just it's
mind-blowing which is one of the things
that led John von Neumann to invent game
theory but he looked at poker I hid the
smartest people of the 20th century yeah
and and and he was like oh he compared
poker to go
I'm sorry protocol to chess and he was
like well chess is not really a game
chess is obviously just a math problem
hooker no that's a game because if
because it involves this conflict
between people were just all about what
I think you think I think right it's
this deeply convoluted back-and-forth of
modeling each other and that's what you
know he wanted to understand and and yet
Jim McManus was a writer who wrote a
wonderful book on poker point out that
at least for a long time every poker
book had six-shooters on the cover of
the book even though they have nothing
to do with playing poker there's this
image of outlaw of degeneracy of living
on the edge that is the opposite of the
image that we have in chess ergo but I
do love the the the mythic figure of the
gambler and it's to me it's always been
a romantical thing it really is a
romantic ideal because I think what the
gambler represents the aliens are
landing here somewhere we're gonna press
on what the mythic archetype of the
gambler represents is the person who has
trained themselves or by their very
personality has a taste for variants a
taste for risk if you're willing to eat
risk you can profit from it and and
there's something powerful and strange
about that because I think randomness
risk probability these are things that
as humans were still trying to wrap our
heads around we still not quite
understand how to think about them
in physics like there's this like deep
debate about how to interpret randomness
whether it exists yeah yeah exactly um
and here we have in in poker an art form
devoted to it which in its own way is is
about getting at some of the same
questions uh how does the world work is
everything yeah
the idea of expectation and the idea of
not being results-oriented is is one
that I love and go or in chess there's a
right or wrong move in every
circumstance you if you don't know what
it is but in poker you might make the
best possible move and still lose yes
and which is what makes it so incredibly
maddening right you can you can work so
hard and you can be sitting at a table
of people who are only there to party
and they've never once thought about how
to play or what the right move is and
you can be playing at such a high level
and they can just be making the donkey
is ever and they can take all of your
money and they can do it over and over
and over again and it's just
soul-crushing
but but that's what makes it to my to my
mind beautiful because you have to
overcome that kind of soul-crushing
quality yeah and and and that's the
sense in which poker can be a spiritual
discipline just like go was you know she
gives some practical advice to the
audience you know if you want to make
money playing poker Vegas 2:00 a.m. when
you've not been drinking is the best
time to play plenty of people who are
there just have a good time yes if you
want to make money at poker
come play me tonight Sean and I are
gonna have a game we're just terrible so
and and but it is it's it's a different
kind of game because it's in some sense
more realistic than go it hasn't been
abstracted down to this pristine set of
situations it's a game of incomplete
information we don't know what's going
to happen right and that's some of the
fun and I also think it's a harder a I
problem for the for that reason it's
really it is yes yeah because it does
involve this kind of reciprocal modeling
and guessing and and it's it's the same
kind of AI problem if all you're trying
to do is develop a cast iron strategy
that is not exploitable in other words
if all you want to do is develop a
strategy that no one else can have a
strategy that will get money from it
right perfect strategy in that sense
that's just a trivial I mean it's not
it's a hard problem but in some sense
it's it's a knowable problem we
understand how to I solve that kind of
problem and it's um but if the problem
you're trying to solve is how can I make
a strategy that is flexible enough
to adapt to the poor play of my
opponents in a way to maximize the edge
I have against other players who are not
playing perfectly then you have a higher
level problem because then you have all
of the psychology of interpreting people
understanding what their strategy is
from their actions and they might be
doing it to you at the same time if go
is human and poker is even more so for
exactly yes
yeah poker is super human and you had
this wonderful quote from Phil Ivey who
is arguably the best poker player in the
world right now I just saw it last night
so I don't know if you remember the
quote yeah where I should give it you
give it an all tell you're all speaking
July be you know just chit-chatting with
other poker players in the middle of the
game said you know when you lose so much
money that you can't breathe
I love that yeah that's what I'm
addicted to that's limiting and it was
beautiful because this was I think um in
in poker after dark when these other
great TV shows and so he wasn't even
aware that necessarily it was kind of
like in the background in the chatter
and it was very honest and as soon as I
heard that I got chills
this idea that that's that weird feeling
of being sick to your stomach that pain
and that is the thing that he was
addicted to I was like I recognize that
and and again there's there is a
darkness there that there's a kind of
destructive energy that's not a good
thing I'm not I'm not here to tell you
oh this is all sweetness and light and
poker is wonderful and you should have
like no this is it's it's horrifying
and and it is destructive right I mean
um but it also can be kind of deeply
meaningful and deeply beautiful so
that's that's what I'm addicted but it's
also a central part of games such as
poker where you lose a lot of money but
even if you're a spectator we just
finished the NHL and NBA playoffs right
yes most teams end their season on a
losing note most fans are disappointed
at the end of the season because they
didn't win the championship there's that
that sense of loss being not maybe not
inevitable but at least likely is a big
part of what brings us to these games
yes unless like me you are the birth in
which case I was very happy okay there
you go yeah but you didn't know that
ahead of time no I did like I as a
Philadelphian I would say that you guys
got lucky
Joel and be basick during playoffs all
right despite all of this masochism and
love for variants and losing and so
forth games are art right I mean it is
it work how do we societally change our
view that the word art is so overloaded
yeah it's just like it's a it's it's
something similar to an art form in the
same sense that you know pop music is is
an art it is an art form it's a creative
form it's an expressive aesthetic form
in that sense I I mean I think I don't
think you can dictate to culture how
culture should interpret things I think
culture is so complicated and nebulous
this process I try to contribute in my
work as a teacher as a designer as a
someone who is out giving talks and so I
do try to get people to be aware of what
it is that people who love games what it
is that they love because I think it can
be confusing
like if you're outside of the world of
games looking in it can look like
nonsense it looks like an explosion in a
cartoon Factory it's like what is
happening this weird violent junk that
my kid is obsessed with and and I do
hope that I can help people who look at
that understand no part of what your kid
is doing is deep problem solving part of
what your kid is doing is exploring a
complex system and forming hypotheses
and and trying to get better part of
what you what your kid is doing is
developing discipline part of what
they're doing is is social and
collaborative and yeah and and so that
doesn't excuse you know people's yeah
some most kids play too many video games
they probably do and and and let balance
yeah but but understanding what is
happening under the hood and and what is
valuable about that I think is the is
the first step toward developing kind of
collectively evolving into a more
sophisticated audience right with a that
that demands better games right that has
a more subtle and and refined sense of
taste for what makes a good game
and pushes the artform in the right
direction I was at a conference maybe 15
years ago so just to put it in social
context but it was about science and
drama and narrative so mostly about
scientists talking to writers and and
English professors and some conversation
was happening and I came up with the
idea I raise my hand said are we gonna
think a few decades from now that the
newest most exciting form of storia
storytelling is games and everyone said
oh no yes
that's not stories because like stories
there's only one thing that happens you
can't have a story where you're not sure
what's gonna happen next I think maybe
we know better now yeah I think some of
the most interesting stuff that's
happening in games is these new forms of
storytelling and both in a traditional
sense where you just have great
characters and and kind of rich world
building kind of woven into into two
game experiences and also in in the kind
of avant-garde sense of exploring what
what a story is like what a story can be
and new forms of narrative and new forms
of storytelling yeah there's a there's a
lot happening in that world that's
really interesting and for the audience
because maybe not everyone is calibrated
here compare the size of the video game
industry to the size of the movie
industry right now it's bigger I don't
know this is it's contentious but but I
think moat by most measures it is
basically the sort of biggest pop
cultural industry right now so when a
game like Red Dead Redemption 2 comes
out it's not just the biggest game
launch in history it's the biggest kind
of entertainment launch in history
so yeah in terms of overall scale as a
commercial industry its its immense
which is is great for me because as
someone who is excited about the
creative possibilities I get to kind of
like tag along right I get to hijack
this this rising tide this commercial
tide which is not my primary interest
I'm Adam I want to make games that make
money I want people to buy my game but
I'm mostly interested in in the creative
potential right and so it's it's good
it's a good healthy
mix honestly but there's a difference
with other forms of mass-market
entertainment and that there's some
barrier to entry it's siloed a little
bit like when a really big movie comes
out everyone knows about it whether or
not they go to see it whereas there's
huge numbers of people who have no idea
what you're talking about when you talk
about Red Dead Redemption yeah but I
mean maybe less and less so over time
like maybe that's just a generational
thing and you know maybe those are be
twenty year old I think I think it's a
pretty well understood touchstone of
culture yeah as much as I go it's an
equip I guess either be the adventurer's
yeah yeah maybe it's not as well-known
as that but it's partly because the
Avengers lives or dies as spectacle yeah
whereas Red Dead Redemption has a
because it is an activity and a hobby
almost lives and dies by a slightly
different cultural logic it's not just
about imprinting itself as an image and
less in fads yeah I did it is about
creating a place and a space that draws
people in and so maybe that's part of
the difference and you've highlighted
the the interplay of emotion and logic I
think it's how you put down and there's
certainly a way that a videogame can be
where it's purely pristinely logical
right you're adding up numbers or you
know getting the shortest path and
there's also a way a game can be I
should have said video any game right
where it's more experiential more
emotional more about how you're feeling
in the moment and is it slightly over
generalizing or is it okay to say
there's a sweet spot where they're both
engaged you know I don't think of it in
terms of a sweet spot where you have
these two things and they're in conflict
instead I think you have these these two
different mindsets right the the kind of
logical rational mindset of you know
this may be reductionist and kind of you
know conscious problem-solving and then
you have the mindset of this kind of
emotional intuitive imaginative
improvisational mindset that is more
fluid and
less kind of logical and analytical I
don't think of those things as being
opposed necessarily I think they're kind
of woven together in a game and so for
an example you take the game chess which
in in one sense is this kind of purely
logical exercise of problem-solving
analytical problem-solving and yet the
chess itself is something like an art
form you know you're doing this
analytical problem-solving because you
find it beautiful because you there is
an emotional connection to it
because you find it expressive and
meaningful and beautiful in ways that
you can't precisely articulate and so in
a sense this this this logical
problem-solving is embedded in in
something that is entirely illogical
right it's not it's not logical to
devote your life to playing chess it's
highly illogical but but but but but we
do it because we we find it beautiful
and and and we find it meaningful and
and and so these things I think are
wrapped around each other it's more of a
fractal fractal structure than it is a
kind of a dialectical certainly
something even with chess ergo there are
styles of play right if you thought of
it as a purely logical expression of
trying to win you might not think there
should be styled what makes Magnusson
thorny in his play forget how they
describe his baby but he's like he's
known as someone who is like stubborn
and and all he's doing is solving a math
problem yeah but but it shows you that
even in the realm of solving math
problems there is nuance there are deep
kind of Shura sticks that we will never
get to the bottom of right even when
problems are well-defined the path that
you take through solution space can be
totally irreducible individualistic yeah
and an expression of who you are as a
person I remember I was on a panel once
with Garry Kasparov who I like to
introduce him as the last human being
who was the best chess player in the
world right yeah now it's computers were
the best but he said something I thought
was very interesting because his
personal style was very aggressive very
fast and there were there's a
conventional wisdom if that was not the
right way to play yeah
and he said when the computers came
along they played that way he felt very
he thought we DS yeah he indicated that
you know it's funny when professional
chess players talk about play they often
use concepts from poker this is another
thing I love about games is that when
you go deep on any one system you find
these resonances right and so they talk
about there's a lot in professional
chess tournament level chess play
there's a lot of predicting what your
opponent's gonna do what openings are
they gonna bring what things are going
to work well against those you want to
spend your time thinking about the right
pathway all right and you can also have
bluffing in chess right you can make a
move and like hope that your opponent
thinks it's a good move but in fact you
don't know for sure whether it is or not
but you're trying to kind of like rattle
them which I just I just love I loved
this mix between these we think we have
these categories we think we know the
difference between logic and emotion but
I think games highlight the ways in
which these things bleed into each other
and I like the idea having styles these
different kind of games it's a different
aspect of this fact that games help with
self-discovery right not just self
discipline but self expressions for to
figuring out who we are yeah I totally
agree and I think any game that you play
is an opportunity to to learn something
about yourself an opportunity to be on
this this path of self-improvement self
overcoming you know what I mean like
this this path that I personally want to
be on as a human where I'm where I'm not
just good at what I'm doing but I'm kind
of improving my idea of what good means
like what what what type of person am I
trying to be you know and I think games
give you an opportunity to do that you
don't have to do most games are not like
that most people don't play games aren't
doing that many people they're just
wasting their time and and they're just
disappearing into us you know a pleasure
a pleasant experience and that's great
you know but I think along the way
there's always this potential and that's
that's what gets me excited if we think
about the history of game design are we
getting better at connecting with the
sublime in our games is that something
that is valued in the community I I
think we are i I think I think we are
get
better and better we just not to say
that it's like a simple straightforward
path so you know that over time we just
get better at you instead it's this
weird security waiting like all forms of
culture are we getting better at music
you know sort of you know and yet there
are ancient pieces of music that I find
deeply moving and so I think games are
similar as a design discipline I do
think we are developing new methods and
and better kinds of best practices and
and a sense of how to do this really
difficult challenging task slightly
better but it is it is irreducible yeah
yeah I mean one aspect of the
self-discovery is given that there are
definitely there's an aspect of being
addicted or being in a zone and losing
yourself there's another aspect of games
that let you become more conscious of
processes that were unconscious right
you had that wonderful example of a game
where you tried to just walk with our
keys yes the keyboard I realized that
walking is really hard yeah tell your
legs what to do yeah this is a wonderful
game by a close friend of mine Bennet
Fadi it also teaches at mru yeah which
is just a game where you're walking and
and it's hilarious because it what he
did was this create this this incredibly
convoluted control scheme where you
control like different limbs and you're
and and so it turns this this trivial
thing into this deeply complicated thing
but you can get good at it I did not get
good at it yeah ten minutes that I spent
give yourself time okay maybe I won't so
what do you think we should wrap up a
little bit two things you can ask answer
which one first you want one is
speculate crazily about the future of
gaming I mean will it become a bigger
bigger entertainment behemoth or will it
sort of blur into the cultural milieu so
the games are everywhere in some sense
and the other is I'm sure we have a
heterogeneous audience in terms of some
people are avid gamers
people never done it for those who have
never done it how should they approach
games there are there certain games they
should think about playing zero is there
a gateway drug I want to answer the
second okay because the first question
it's too hard to predict culture
everything you have fans are both just
ordering did this first one person I'll
just knock it out of the park and move
on um it the job of a game designer is
to answer that question right every game
designer is trying to figure out what
the future of games is and it is going
to be and what it should be and so in
the process of making games we are
actively fulfilling that kind of role of
predicting what the future of games is
gonna be so that's my short answer delay
the the second question of what yeah a
lot of times people come up to me and
and you know what kind of game should i
play how do I get into this world what I
like to tell them is find a game that
your friends are playing and play that
like it's it's it's so much it's so much
more important that you play a game as
part of a living community then that you
played the right game play a game that
other people are playing that you can
then talk to them about it like you can
learn from them say well what did you
like what did I you know yeah I didn't
get very far I'm stuck here or that you
can play with them and and sort of like
think about the game as being part of a
social practice where people communicate
with each other through the game I think
that's I think that's more important
than playing just the right kind of like
little masterpiece that's going to like
this whole idea of masterpieces you
don't mean like like we have a running
joke in game design about Citizen Kane
oh there's the Citizen Kane of games and
and um but I think games by their nature
are so squirrely right they are so
evanescent and and and they're so weird
that they don't fit into that little
tidy box of what a masterpiece is right
they don't fit into this this thing
where oh yes I can take an object and
put it on a pedestal and look at it and
see its characteristics and and thereby
get some aesthetic experience because
they're participatory
and so so it's less important that you
play sync up house the greatest game
that you can play right now is a game I
love buy my game designer Michael burrow
it's more important that you play
something that you have a context a
social context for and that you can talk
to people about and learn and and be
motivated to participate in so I mean
there's an introvert part of me inside
that says but I just want to ignore
other people when I'm playing games but
I remember that you know a really good
poker table really matters the other
people you're playing with is a huge
part of the spirit it's really true I
often think if I were in a place and and
I was given an option I was with a bunch
of people and I was given an option you
go in a room a and play this game that
you know is a great game but play it
with these people or maybe a bunch of
jerks or you go in this other room and
play a game that maybe is not so good
and its own but with these wonderful
people that you love and you think are
really interesting and clever it's
always better to do this - there's a lot
to think about about the future of this
I think that we're just starting really
with where games can go so franklin's
thanks so much for being on the podcast
thank you logging and Santa pay and the
interplanetary festival thanks so much
for having us and thank you very much
the audience for helping us with this
experience it's been a lot of fun thanks
[Music]
you
[Music]